[Music]
how is it going reject nation it is I
John coming at you got a new trailer
actually for the new Sabrina of the
Teenage Witch series chilling Adventures
of Sabrina coming to you on Netflix and
you might be asking yourself John why
are you watching this
um and the short answer is I'm a big
Riverdale fan I've been you know aware
of the Archie comics universe for a
while I caught some secondhand episodes
of Sabrina growing up and I've been
actually covering a Riverdale on patreon
shameless plug time we cover a lot of TV
shows over on our patreon and one of
those shows is Riverdale it's one of the
shows that I cover covered all of season
one over there most of the way through
season two I'll probably just hop into
season three whenever I wrap up the
second season just cuz you know it
starts airing in like a week yeah I've
got a whole bunch of Riverdale reactions
over there as well as some other shows
like live-action stuff including Gotham
and supernatural we just started up and
then anime is well with my hero academia
Full Metal Alchemist and attack on Titan
and we're you know always adding new
stuff over there so come check us out if
you're so inclined but yeah I don't know
I really wanted to check this out I've
really been enjoying what they've done
with Riverdale so far and from what I
understand this is the same creator
showrunner behind the chilling
adventures of Sabrina they have some
definite horror influences that they
wear heavily on their sleeves so I'm
very excited to see that Venn diagram
overlap that much more with this horror
is one of my favorite things so the
Archie vibe plus horror you just can't
get any better for me so let's hop into
this let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
what's that guy in the town of Greendale
weird always there lived a girl who was
halfway on her sixteenth birthday would
have to choose between two worlds the
witch world of her family and the human
auto for friends oh damn
[Music]
oh you must know
Oh rubble stone that's how I like my
watches but these are desperate times
[Music]
[Music]
is Sabrina Spellman
would you like to do the honors with
pleasure
oh okay interesting it's an interesting
note to end on leave me with some
questions there that looks like a lot of
fun man I mean that looks kind of
exactly what the pitch sort of was which
is you know is spiraling off a river
down I mean the Sabrina spiraled out of
the Riverdale comics anyway off the bat
I mean that's fun I don't know how much
if at all they're gonna cross over I've
heard they're not planning on crossing
over very soon anyway but you know we've
seen Greendale at least for a second and
they mention it every now and again on
Riverdale but yeah this looks like just
kind of a perfect blend of that high
school coming-of-age vibe with some much
more in-your-face horror movie elements
and I know that Sabrina at least the
chilling Adventures of Sabrina comics
were inspired by you know the horror of
the 60s and 70s stuff like Rosemary's
Baby and things like that and from what
I've heard the creator's say they're
going for a similar vibe with this and I
think that's a cool flavor to go with
for a show in this universe I mean again
I don't know what the overlap is because
they're different networks but I mean at
least as a horror fan I think this looks
really cool I mean I love these
creatures and this whole witch world
they've got here you've got these people
hanging from trees and demons and stuff
like that and pretty you know imposing
looking group of witches that she's
rolling with at least in this trailer
and you know there's a central hook at
hand or 16th birthday is coming up she's
gonna have to choose you know which path
she wants to follow and I got imagine
that's gonna inform the arc of this
first season here and I imagine that
could create some pretty interesting
character conflict if she's kind of
being pulled between the witch world and
the human world I mean we started this
trailer off with her and her boyfriend
so I got imagine them there might be at
least a debate to have there even if you
I mean you know she's gonna end up doing
witchcraft and stuff with her powers but
I wonder how that conflict is gonna
figure in but I don't know just the same
way Riverdale is a town with the
personality unto itself you know I
imagine Greendale will probably be a
town with the first
now D unto itself is more Halloween in
this show and I like the supporting cast
- I mean Kiernan Shipka like she's
terrific and everything I've seen her in
and I am excited to see her lead this
especially they have a moment where
she's like it's Sabrina Spellman even
just cut up for a trailer I was like oh
[ __ ] like this is good to be pretty
gripping I love that you got Lucy Davis
and Miranda Otto and here being her
aunts I'm excited to see them you know
play off each other I think both of them
are really great actresses and they got
you know some pretty good earmarks in
here from the comics the first scene
she's out with Harvey and he's you know
taunting her with some Night of the
Living Dead bringing more of those
horror influences in you know because
Riverdale like they make it clear how
much they love certain horror I'm about
to watch the episode where they do they
carry the music oh you know you got a
brief glimpse at least of Salem in here
I wonder if they're gonna go with the
more popular version of Salem where he's
talking all the time or if they're gonna
go way back to basics but I've got to
imagine that there's gonna be some kind
of you know rapport with Salem there
especially for Halloween season I'm
gonna be really excited to check this
out don't know if I'll do reactions are
not on patreon but I would certainly be
interested in doing them at the very
least but yeah like as the first
official trailer for this show I'm
definitely hooked I love the look of it
I mean one thing that Riverdale has it's
great is the cinematography is always on
point it always looks very picturesque
like it was ripped out of a comic book
or something like that
I love the aesthetics and the set
designs I'm seeing here I love some of
the horror and witchy imagery it seems
like they're not gonna skimp or soften
that too much and I appreciate again
this new iteration of Archie where it
does kind of have an edge and this looks
like it's gonna take that edge that much
further so I am actually very excited to
finally see this and you know also for
the humor elements it looks like there's
gonna be some pretty good humor as well
so uh yeah what did you guys think
though hit me up in the comments let me
know your thoughts are you a big Sabrina
fan are you looking forward to this do
you not like it all the direction
they're taking here you into Riverdale
do you hope they'll cross over sound off
and let me know and until next time
party people Cheers
hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm Kat
I gave you an opportunity thank you I
let woman speak cat is on Instagram and
Twitter and faith here Twitter yeah I
have Twitter I'm at the cat Alvarado on
everything and in Facebook I'm cat out
the cat Alvarado comedies and not
everything you know what's everything
these [ __ ] new shirts we got here I
got a shirt from cat Alvarado
representing her awesome comedy March
she has a cool shirt here believe in
soulmates like reading it and then you
get there and you're like oh that's
actually what month are we in cat we're
in October you know that means horror
season time and you know what I like to
do what yeah Kevin McCallister home
alone we're you gonna watch this Netflix
trailer that got a few requests for it's
called the haunting of Hell House do you
watch horror sometimes jinx okay let's
watch the spear shall we let's
transition scary piano sounds why is
piano so scary
but baby is scary-looking
I'm sure we can handle any dreamer there
the weirdest what is
[Music]
he has to die
in time a soldier people
[Music]
you wake us up like that what the hell
is going on
this is where we go out
Hill House
is that in the houses or she was not
crazy
are you guys at Game of Thrones
really bad dream of course that it's the
best what-if game I've ever heard child
ever play it's the best what-if game
okay and this is a series yeah okay it
sounds kind of like it's gonna be
American Horror Story kind of the first
season of American Horror Story was
about a haunted yeah yeah but this has
the house on Haunted Hill kind of vibe
except they're calling this the haunting
of Hell House yeah the idea of this
being a series seems a little bit more
intriguing to me than actually being a
movie like a movi the others would feel
rushed not really have time to develop
where I think in a show you could really
developed it I feel like I'll probably
start off a little slow and then it
eventually escalate into the strangest
territory I think it's got potential
like I can see it starting off like oh
this is gonna be haunted thing and then
it's gonna go in a direction that we
don't know it's gonna go in it might be
a little bit lost like where it's like
okay we're gonna chase after this is it
gonna be confusing even just with the
kids playing that what-if game because I
like the way that trailer did that like
hey what if this happens you know kids
always do that they'd be great at improv
those kids oh yeah man imaginations like
what are they watching on TV is that the
first episode heartbreak forever what
are you 30 okay was she dreaming that
was that a real conversation she was
[Laughter]
really familiar but who hasn't played a
what-if game like that would their
parents you know hey mommy what if I got
murdered and someone tied you down and
had to watch me get murdered the whole
time in front of you I played that game
my Filipino mother all the time yeah
what if nobody loves me forever and
I get really sad about it would you
still love me marry me have a wedding
one day the girls what if no that just
sounds like you're gonna be a cat lady
carla Gugino started a Netflix horror
movie last year called Gerald's game
it's kind of cool that she's keeping
this horror tradition on Netflix going
some of the scare stuff looks a little
generic I also like that it seems like
it's going for a little bit something
more subtle not too in-your-face about
it I feel like if it was so in-your-face
it would feel exactly like American
Horror Story
it's American Horror Story all the
seasons have this like really fast-paced
thing going on about it
this feels like it'll have a lot of
dread be more about its atmosphere and
mood more than it would be about like a
bunch of freaky looking things happening
left and right except you do got kind of
this like Japanese horror thing going on
just be like someone with wet hair like
tucking their daughter and after a bath
right yeah just doing that is really a
comedy that's being advertised is it
Japanese horror
yeah you've nailed Japanese horror just
right there the most famous haunted
house in America okay oh it's a novel
yeah okay yeah let's read the novel oh
so this was originally a movie a 1959
gothic horror movie I should know that I
watch all kinds of 50 gothic horror
movies well this might upset some people
I imagine just because Oh Mike Flanagan
directed this and Mike Flanagan he
directed Gerald's game which hat no no
wonder she's in this I like this guy's
movies I like the movie hush
I like Gerald's game those movies are a
lot more grounded and realism so I think
that's why I'm kind of drawn to this
material because like I said this could
be something that's really
below now with all its crazy
supernatural stuff but it feels a lot
more grounded I think that's a more
unique approach to tape but like I said
it could be a really slow-moving show
that might not be all that interesting
how do you really like draw horror like
that episode by episode by episode but
like you just have a normal day and yeah
happens to be like a lady standing in
the background and they're like hey did
you see that lady's right yeah because
that's a good point because buildup in a
in a horror movie is one thing cuz
that's a movie and you have time to like
let it audience be patient but if what
if I watched one episode anomaly nothing
really happened to that exciting do I
really care about this it's like they
just have the whole episode go they're
like oh my god then yeah like that could
working out and a movie but in a show
I'm not sure either way I mean I kind of
want to check out the original film now
I'm not gonna read the book but I might
check out the original film and then do
a whole comparison and then just be mad
at them to show the entire time I think
it's a great idea it's a wonderful use
of time no I mean really it made for you
really for you because this is what you
do I'm not being where it is
condescending and sincerity with you it
sounds like a crazier time so you're
gonna watch it yeah watch it
can i watch it with you and your
girlfriend yeah just come over hang out
with the - yeah cats always around here
yeah that'd be that'd be super
comfortable we'll just put up another
couple of extra pillows to divide okay
sleep next to my girl I'll sleep on the
ground yeah all right guys well are you
gonna watch this does this trailer upset
you because it doesn't look like a movie
from 60 years ago comment below you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification about again
notifications and also follow Kat album
righto on Facebook the cat Alvarado
comedy no cat Alvarado comedy Instagram
the cat Alvarado where she does not pose
in bikini photos but she's got a lovely
smile so it's so worth your time boys
also follow her on Twitter where she
does not post bikini photos no it's
mostly just snarky comments about
politics yeah just what you want and you
never know you never know